you know what's [ __ ] up african people
don't like black people
y'all know they treat us like [ __ ] they
talk down to us they think they're
better than us
and i don't understand because we're
from the same tribe
kind of but they like white people
though they treat y'all like family
as soon as y'all come around they get
excited excuse me mr white man
thank you for bringing us here we love
you
yay the white mommy
soon as they see us they get an attitude
hey how you doing this [ __ ]
we don't like the black man in america
[ __ ] you don't work you don't do
[ __ ]
we don't like you you black [ __ ]
like who are you calling black
[ __ ] i'm brown you midnight who
the [ __ ] are you calling black
like [ __ ] if you stood up against the
building you look like an ally who the
[ __ ] are you going
the [ __ ] is unjust
african men don't understand why when
they come to america they have a hard
time getting american [ __ ]
you can't be that aggressive with
american women especially black women
you got to know how to talk you got to
come correct mohammed's in africa is
used to having they weight i got 15
wives and [ __ ]
and african women are very obedient they
tell they women what to do it's not even
the issue
[ __ ] when they come home you
i don't know why they do that did you
you you better you better clean this
[ __ ] from the floor i don't
maybe in the club's stalking women out
here you can't even see them they be as
black as my jacket
you just see the yellow of their eyes
from a distance looking like congo in
the bush
as soon as you go buy your drink they
jump out the shadows and scare the [ __ ]
at you [ __ ] what is your name
come here don't run from me
[Applause]
you're going to be my wife
what you're hunters last night the epic
disaster film twister opened to big box
office and
some controversy the reverend jesse
jackson has called for a boycott of the
movie
claiming that not enough black people in
the film are killed by a tornado
my kids got baptized at a black church
wasn't prepared for that
i mean i just i i prefer white shirts
myself
black chairs just takes too long for me
you got to have your day free
you can't make no plans going to a black
church
yep you found going to a football game
you ain't gonna make it
hey you might not make money tonight
football while you're bullshitting
is ridiculous man remember the first
time i went to black church i
ain't gonna take that long you know like
i didn't eat breakfast that morning i
thought i was getting about an hour
you know my god almost died in my
nutrition that day
wait for sally strothers to pop up you
know
i was i was sitting in the church man i
was like why is this taking so long you
know
i figured out having the service service
while it's taking so long because um
you know when you when you're in church
white people man we don't say nothing
you know
we shut up and we listen you know if
somebody tries to talk while preachers
talk and we tell them
zip it focus okay one more song we're
gone
remember first i went to black church um
i i didn't know i didn't know
that when black people agree what the
service is about they don't wait they
get up right there that they agree i
don't know kdl out
i'm sitting there i don't know why i got
in the whole church i'm getting upset
with all the black people pews around me
you know
i thought they were being disrespectful
to the preacher i know kdl out i'm just
sitting there
preach on it are you serious just going
to talk while he's talking
yeah that's very disrespectful won't you
zip it in focus it's 1 30. i'm ready to
go home
talk about it are you with him
what you're allowed to talk
are you serious i'm gonna say something
let me watch i'm gonna say something
come on it's 4 30.
another song is she singing rihanna
that's nothing to do with church
it's six o'clock
you guys have a step team are you
serious
the first baptist steppers it's 8 30.
a freaking poet this is a talent show
that's the fourth time she got the holy
ghost she's lying
you can't catch the holy ghost four
times in one day it's 10
30. stop
passing this plate around i don't have
any more money
it's midnight
it's monday i'm late for work
it takes forever man so i've been seeing
this girl recently uh
it's black girl right she lives up in
harlem you know gone out like three four
times you know first time we hung out
we hung out like the village area in new
york you know which is sort of like a
racially mixed area
so [ __ ] was cool you know what i mean
second time you hung out was more like
midtown you know
then the third time she called me at
like 3 30 in the morning and she wanted
me to come up to her apartment right
so it's 3 30 in the morning she lives in
harlem i look how i look so it's a
[ __ ] situation
yeah because you know the deal right
basically a white dude feels comfortable
up to about like 98
99th street you know what i'm saying the
second the streets start getting into
like triple digits like 100 101st street
start getting like a little asthma like
[ __ ] you're starting to get a little
high up here
you feel that little tightness in your
chest can you feel that
106th street you're like leaning on [ __ ]
like dude where'd all the cabs go
how come there's no taxis up here
dude what's a bodega i don't know what
that is let's get the [ __ ] out of here
so i'm praying to god she's going to
tell me to take the subway get off at
like 105th street 1003 you know which is
like the first stop in harlem where i
can still look over my shoulder
and see like all the white people like
disappearing over the horizon you know
but she goes no man you want to get in
the uptown 2-3 train you want to get off
at 125th stream like ah [ __ ] on 25th
street
[Applause]
jesus christ that's like right in the
middle of everything
i'm gonna be surrounded on all four
sides i can't [ __ ] do this
so at this point i'm really trying to
hide like the [ __ ] tone that's
starting to creep into my voice you know
and i'm trying to ask for really
specific directions for when i get up
there because i want to know exactly
where i'm going
so she starts naming the streets i have
to go down and every other street up
there is named that's like a black
leader you know she's like make a left
on adam clayton
take a right on frederick douglas i'm
like [ __ ] out of clayton
now dude go on the internet look at that
and play
did he kill a bunch of white people
during the slave revolt
dude i going up there so i know what i'm
saying to flip this [ __ ]
[Applause]
so at this point i'm really having a
battle with myself
because i'm thinking i can't do this
right i'm like i can't do this but my
dick's going now come on man we can do
this all right
just relax pull yourself together
and get on the goddamn train right so as
always i listen to my dick
oh yeah i get on the train by the time i
get up there it's like five or four in
the morning right i'm staying on like
malcolm x and like danny glover or some
[ __ ] right
i don't even know where the hell i'm at
when i see the street i want to go up i
want to go up saint nick i can literally
see her apartment building but there's
like
five or six black dudes standing right
on the corner right where i want to walk
by so i'm like [ __ ]
i thought i was on like some reality
show at that point like some sort of
like white guy survivor it was
ridiculous
so i'm thinking i gotta walk right by
these guys right you know what's funny i
think that they were actually more
surprised to see me then i was scared
you know
and i was really really scared you know
but i'm also really really white you
know
like shockingly caucasian
you know like if you're not ready for me
i can like surprise you
no especially if you live up there
you've probably seen a white person for
hours
possibly days so when i show up it's
almost like magical like a leprechaun
came out of nowhere you know
felt like i should have like a little
pot of gold like a rainbow behind me top
of the morning too you like
it just kind of dance my way past them
but it's been going all right you know
once i get in her apartment i'm fine you
know i relax
sit down you know watch a hip-hop
countdown
pretend like i know the groups you know
what i mean
it's just getting there that's a [ __ ]
pain in the ass
but you know i don't get mad at it
because i figure you know black dude's
got to go through the same [ __ ] though
right when you go into the suburbs go
[ __ ] a white girl
right just that same awful feeling
of just leaving your people behind you
know just less and less of you as you're
[ __ ] driving out there
probably start off lean and you're all
[ __ ] cool 20 minutes in you're
driving like 10 and two the waves are
like dude
i like this [ __ ] i don't like this [ __ ]
at all
there's too much grass i don't see any
rims
this is [ __ ] up none of the windows
are tinted i can clearly see white
people in every car this is [ __ ] up
[Applause]
i just want to say i'm not trying to say
that if you're white you can't complain
right i'm just saying that if you're
black you get to complain more right
right because you can't
there you go don't tell the band that
yeah yeah yeah yeah
because you can't you get this right you
can't take people's
like historical context away from them
and everybody wants this to like white
people are always like come on
it wasn't us like they want black people
to forget everything
like every year white people add a
hundred years to how long ago slavery
was
i've heard educated white people say
slavery was 400 years ago
no it very wasn't it was 140 years ago
that's two
70 year old ladies living and dying back
to back
that's how recently you could buy a guy
that's right and it's not like slavery
ended and then everything has been
amazing like it just oh glad that's over
oh yeah it just
ended like a clean where you don't have
to wipe just boom
and then it's just been parades
and presents ever since you got it
you got to remember that if you meet a
black person they have gray hair they
remember a time they weren't allowed to
use a certain toilet
so give them a little you know time to
be cranky and by the way white people
have our own thing that we
stuff that we went sure sure that that
hurt us that we have to cope with like
when they took our slaves away that was
really
hard for us and we're still
so it's pretty even it's okay so it's
even yeah it's even
but i didn't always know that was a
black thing it took me a while to
figure that out i learned that [ __ ] in
new york
i was in new york city
now i was hanging out with a friend of
mine he's a white guy you know we were
just hanging out
and we were lost in the city you know
he's smoking a joint now i don't know it
was a coincidence that we were
lost and high and [ __ ] but
my wife buddy he was smoking a joint
dave dave it's the goddamn cops
i'm gonna ask him for directions
i said chip no chip don't do it
it was too late he was walking over
there this man was high as [ __ ]
excuse me excuse me sir
touching him and [ __ ] excuse me
[Music]
you need some information start
confessing things you shouldn't confess
i'm a little high
all i want to know which way is third
street the cow was like hey
take it easy
you're on third street
you better be careful go ahead move it
move it
that's all that happened that's another
story
now i know that's not amazing to some of
you
but she has one of these black fellas
that [ __ ] is [ __ ] incredible isn't it
i'm saying a black man would never dream
of talking to the police
that's a waste of weed
serious
i mean i'll be scared to talk to the
police when i'm sleepy
they [ __ ] around get the wrong ideas you
know
oh my god that [ __ ] was on pcp johnson
i had to use necessary force you saw
them
no no no paperwork just just sprinkle
some crack on them let's get out of here